اكيد لان المملكه بشكل عام
بمساحتها في استيطان على مدار السنين من
عصور ما قبل التاريخ يعني نحكي من واحد
فاصله خمسه مليون سنه في نجران الى اليوم
في استمراريه طرق طرق الحج على الفترات
الاسلاميه طرق التجاره كانت الحروب كلها
اللي صارت مع الاشوريين ومع البابليين
كانت بسبب وحتى مع الانباط والرومان
سيطرتهم عليها بسبب طرق التجاره فهذا سبب
اساسي كان موجود
وغير هذا كمان عندنا استيطان بشكل مستمر
الطبيعه المناخيه كانت تختلف من الاف
السنين حتى على مستوى الربع الخالي كانت
تختلف في الطبيعه المناخيه ما كان بهذه
الصحراء اللي نعرفها اليوم
طبعا الطبيعه المناخيه تتكلمين عن العصور
المطيره يعني انه كان في انهار كان فيه
تجمعات مياه بالتالي توفر قدره على
الاستيطان حوالينها يعني يعني عندك مثلا
من واحد مليون سنه كان في ثلاث اكبر انهار
تشق الجزيره العربيه من ضمنها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتصب الخليج العربي هذه
الانهار حوالينا في استيطان حتى كانت
قريبه من نجد وفي عندك لما تشوف الصور
مثلا الرياض كيف كانت او منطقه نجذب بشكل
عام كل منطقه استوائيه فالواحد لما يشوفها
ممكن ما تصدق ان هذا الشيء كان من مليون
سنه فهذا شيء دائما ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
بالتنقيب عن المواقع نشوف كيف كانت
الطبيعه المناخيه قبل وهنا نستعين
انما نرجعها مثلا الى حوالي مليون سنه
للخلف عشان نتخيل كيف كان نشاط البشره
هناك البشر والحيوانات طبعا والحركه يعني
لو واحد بيسوي فيلم زي ابع اد ثلاثيه زي
افاتار ممكن يتخيل بدون مبالغه بس بدون
الزرع